so you want to make money on YouTube
well there's three rules that you have
to learn first take it from number one
rule number one I mean you gotta have
really cool expensive clothing 100%
legit you guys already know what it is
it didn't fit me but I found someone who
it fits better and he's gonna buy it
straight catcher I don't know I just the
ugliest hoodie I have seen in my entire
life
rule number two you need a very
expensive vehicle of Transportation who
would have ever thought three years
after I graduated from high school I'll
be going to pull up in a Lamborghini
how would saying is that guys I really
hope you guys do enjoy this video I'm
also bringing this giant camera because
I'm having my cousin record everyone's
reaction as well there's gonna be a dope
video and guys smash that like button if
you'd want me to come pick you up from
school in a Lamborghini how do you
delete the like button is it possible so
you don't actually watch is mole rat
looking twig it's beyond me rule number
three you need hella [ __ ]
I wish for health happiness and hella
[ __ ] so if you want to make it on
YouTube but you don't have it these
three things so just don't make me life
there there is however one more answer
you can just be a Swedish [ __ ] boy that
complains about literally everything and
just shits on everyone that that seems
to be working as well all right here we
go
so here's views here's flexing and
here's here's how they increase look at
that now the other option that you have
is to just [ __ ] on everyone else and get
used by doing that as well this is
actually surprisingly accurate today's
video topic as you may have guessed is
flexing on kids it seemed like internet
fame these days well it's always been to
be honest is the goal that you want to
have is to how can you get an army of
kids to watch
kids will buy your merch and they will
click on literally any video no matter
what the quality is of it one who
controls the kids controls the universe
[Music]
controls history
do I sound bitter enough for you don't
worry we're just getting started if you
want to be a vlogger on YouTube
especially vloggers know more than
anyone else that flexing equals views
it's just a scientific fact I am right
about everything and I've never been
wrong in my entire life so I'm gonna
tweet out is there a single popular vlog
channel on YouTube that doesn't involve
at least some level of flexing as part
of their program send me
prove me wrong Casey Casey nice day
[Laughter]
$21,000 first class airplane seat 18,000
a night hotel room moving on pro
syndicate gala let's have a look here
alright buying my granddad his dream car
okay alright
New Zealand in first class out okay
alright okay
Russia in first class okay all right
okay all right breed raisers way it's my
house is finally done New York first
guys no you're right you guys were right
but it is Mars bars vlogs well not you
you gotta be trolling with me listen I'm
sure these guys make great videos I'm
just trying to prove a point and that is
flexing equals views no matter who you
are um david dobrik alright okay fine
let's have a look our new house
surprising my girlfriend with a Teslin
alright he's kind of flexing on his
girlfriend more than anything well
define it's the rule is still counting
see guys there's no way I'm wrong about
this I've been right every single time
in my life Julian so Lomita
okay fine there's one exception to the
rule whatever god damn it Julie and I
was trying to prove a point
flexing equals views because kids like
to watch it and go wow that's so cool
because kids are morons if you're a kid
watching just know that you're an idiot
and I don't like you please buy my chair
when I was a kid more than anything in
the world what I wanted a Gibson guitar
so I would constantly go into guitar
stores to either try them out or just
look at them that gave me enough joy to
just admire them I don't even play
guitar anymore do you see do you see
where I'm getting at here you think you
want something but you don't
vlogging on YouTube has essentially
become the new window shopping and
vloggers know this more than anything
and this really goes beyond
materialistic things it goes into
portraying oh look we're such a great
family don't you wish you had such a
great family to watch our vlogs what
what we're divorced what what oh look at
me and my girlfriend together we are so
happy there's nothing bad in our
relationship we broke up what look how
happy I am in all of my videos all the
time you could be happy too as long as
you live my lifestyle what I'm depressed
how did this happen it's almost like I
portrayed an image that was inaccurate
to Who I am and then they'll make a
video even about their depression clique
fading that as well how far does it go
how low can you go with all these things
is it all about showing off these days
is that the only thing that matters all
the time these days are you just see
money in the title of videos and it's
pretty much everywhere let's see how low
we can go let's look at this come
straight up go into the bank in this
video holding out five thousand all of
cash and I'm gonna be hiding it for you
guys real money in your [ __ ] hand
shit's gonna get a while if you guys
like this idea you guys want me to do
this against Mac so you don't
accidentally called me out
[Music]
donating one thousand two random twitch
streamers these are quite popular these
days there's no freaking way this is a
stolen concept from that mr. B's dead
donating ten thousand to four night
stream if they win the thing about these
videos is that if you don't add just a
thousand dollars I know just a thousand
but if you get 1.5 million users in the
video you'll make that money back and
more and you get more views on your
other videos as well so it's not it's
really not a big deal and it's a great
way if you like any form of likable
personality and or original ideas to
videos it's a great way to just flex on
them kids you know and ever since mr.
beasts made the video of it and got
millions and millions of views the mole
ride community just swarmed across this
idea and finally finally there's a video
idea I can make where I don't have to
show my personality but I can just show
off that I have a lot of money and
that's making even more money but now
it's not just about it click betting
kids to watch your expensive lifestyle
it now it's even gone so far that you
can sell this idea that you can live my
lifestyle or if only you pay me $64 you
may have heard of this but Jake Paul
announced this sort of masterclass
parody coffee whatever where you have to
take a quiz to find out what kind of
youtuber you are or one to be you enter
your email and then you get to watch
this video
what is up guys
I'm Jake Paul and if you know me you
probably know all about team 10 as well
and at the end of this video I have a
crazy new announcement about something
I'm calling team 1000 but guys let me
slow down a little bit because there
wasn't always fancy cars and nice hotels
listen up that's right I come from the
bottom and if you want to be rich to
just pay us $64 and you can learn how I
make youtube videos would you like to
own a home like this looking barely
afford to pay your rent my name is
Jordan Belfort and there's no secret to
wealth creation no matter who you are no
matter where you came from you too can
become financially independent
independently I am now financially
independently I'm the number one
youtuber and I'm gonna tell it honestly
and straight as possible that the key to
success is this you have to buy my chair
it's 399 and if you it's really
comfortable so you can become a great
fantastic handsome wonderful youtuber
like me but only by by buying this chair
and also it can yes
you're welcome everyone you're welcome
for someone that doesn't really get it I
don't get the whole flexing thing sure
if you want to buy expensive things and
you want to feel proud of it and showing
it off is that illegal
now of course not there's no shame in
that but that's not really what we're
discussing here either is it this whole
obsession with money and showing off
wealth it feels like I'm watching a
bunch of Neanderthals in front of a
shiny object oh whoa whoa oh wow look at
that it's pathetic
it's lowlife and don't buy into this
idea stop buying in today's idea and I'm
so sick of seeing it everywhere in music
industry it's the thing that sells the
most and every rapper ever that you
listen to is all about just flexing and
showing up that there might have money
and it's so sickening and and I and I to
keep asking like where does the line
draw where do people stop caring about
money and actually care about some form
of respect is that how high is that
price for people because it seems like
it's getting higher and higher and
higher how much people just want wealth
more than anything you add the rapper
twenty one Savage who built his brand
around street cred but no he made a
video with Jake Paul why by y21
why did you yeah you know what I'm a
deejay you always doing music stuff
apparently 21 announced a couple this is
a couple months ago but now he announced
that he is no longer going to spend
money on chains and he's no longer going
to buy all these other things to show
off wealth and he wants to start
investing into property and stuff like
that instead 21 savage no longer wears
jewelry buying houses investing in
businesses crypto new startups is what
he want to make cool for young rappers
to do thank you thank you thank you 21
he's back everybody I was so glad to
hear this cuz I hope at least this means
that more people are waking up to the
idea that it's not cool to idolize these
fools this idiots these gun banks be
smart about your wealth and stop
clicking on videos that has my
signs in the thumbnail you dummy